without further ado we'd like to direct
everyone's attention
to the video boards the number 15 will
take its rightful place above ashburn
alley
where it will reside in perpetuity in
honor
of the distinguished career of our
friend dick allen with the help of
michael jack schmidt
the phillies will officially retire
number 15 on the count of
three two one
michael
i'd like to thank john
middleton mike schmidt
mike dolan everybody along the way
and all the fans of philadelphia
for this honorable moment
and i'll say it again thanks so much
john
it means a lot to me and my family
as drupal cabrera stands in swing and a
miss he got him 96.
and now the phillies come to bat against
36 year old right-hander alibaul sanchez
1-4 record of 6.90 era as he faces
roman quinn for the wide first pitch
fastball pull to the ground right side
diving stop luis garcia
up to a knee and throws to cabrera in
time for the out a gem
by the second baseman garcia
jt rilmuto is the batter out to right
field going back on it is adam eaton to
the scoreboard it's off the top of the
scoreboard
harper to third the throw goes to second
and harper thought about taking off once
he stopped at third
it'll be a double for jt his fifth of
the year
second and third two outs all right so
two out base hit is what the phillies
need here d.d gregorius the hitter
that one's hit sharply on one hot right
between the legs of hulk
two runs will score and the phillies
take a two nothing lead here in the
bottom of the first inning
some good two out hits
a straight turn everyone has five
strikeouts the last three of them have
been looking
good speed at second and garcia with two
outs
and turner to center back is quinn
jumping it's off the very top of the
wall
and trey turner is going to have at
least three right here the ball rolling
around
here he comes looks like an inside the
park home run
see you later it's a 2-2
game quinn tried to make the leaping
catch slammed into the fence so he was
out of the play
by the time bruce recovered turner was
circling the bases
well it hit at the very top of that 13
foot three inch wall
in right center field i'm thinking as
soon as that ball hit the wall it was a
home run
watch watch straight run are you kidding
me that's full throttle folks
you don't see that too often oh man that
is cool
phil's two nationals two we start the
home half of the
third inning and it'll be rhys hoskins
to lead off for the fills
that ball is hit out toward left field
the belt's not going to help him there
it's gone a home run for reese hoskins
it's another one
he's homer now six times in his last
nine games and the phillies retake the
lead
how good is he feeling right now
with the struggles he's been through and
and just completely
turn it around night and day last what
you say 21 games he was hitting 325
with all kinds of production
bring up d.d gregorius he's running
again and he's
gonna score that bull's head out toward
right center field over the head of
roblaise jt
held up for a moment it's bobbled by
robles so jt is going to score easily
it's now four to two wander suero
moves into a real tight spot where the
bases loaded one out to face bryce
harper
set for suero he deals strike three on a
cutter is swinging a miss to the outside
and a big second out of the inning as
suero strikes out harper
not out of the woods yet however with jt
rio muto coming up
he deals strike three caught on a change
up at the belt to the outside and wander
suero
comes in to put out the fire the
phillies leave the bases loaded
advancing garcia to third and robles
into scoring position at second trade
turn to the batter here's a swing of the
chopper over the mound
charging in gregorius has it in front of
second his throw to first
is in time to get turner as garcia comes
in to score from third
it's a 4-3 game two out tying run at
third for juan soto
and he'll drive one to center that's a
base hit
and this game is tight we'll take over
last night and phelps will face the
bottom of the order which has been tough
the bottom of the order scored three of
the four runs
over to first and off the glove of reese
head into right field so
they throw behind him and he's out at
first base he got a little
soft and bryce harper was able to pick
him off
you know bryce looks up he sees you guys
sees garcia not looking and throws
behind him great short hot pick by
phelps though
michael a taylor first at bat in the
series
one for five with a solo homer and a
walk
fastball taylor high and deep
left center c u
later his second of the series
and for the first time in the last six
games the nationals have a lead
and it's provided by the big hit of
michael taylor
well that had a big sound off the crack
of the bat
and there was no question that pitch was
grooved middle
in and belt high and he did not miss it
the phillies have the bases loaded and
andrew mccutchen has been
introduced as a pinch hitter to face the
new pitcher
daniel hudson ground ball out towards
shortstop
picked up by turner flips to second for
one that's all they'll get the game is
tied up
an rvi for mccutchen the bases are now
loaded and teller goes to third and
it'll bring brock holt
up pulled toward first base and reece
has got it
he'll take it to the bag himself and the
inning is over
so alec baum well he's got a three hit
game
four hit game would win it for the
phillies but he doesn't need to win it
with a hit
bottom of the 10th inning here's the
pitch with the bases loaded hits it high
in the air to center field real muto
will tag
roblace is under it it's not deep
roadblaze makes the catch renuta is
going home
roblox is thrown to the plate not in
time
the phillies win it on a sacrifice fly
by the rookie alec balm they win it six
to five
here at the bottom of the tenth inning a
walk-off
sac fly